Patt 40 Sports Illustrated senior writer
looking good joining us on the program
Pat good morning how's morale over and
over my if my hair grows any longer I'm
gonna be an honorary Allman brother here
pretty soon all right
simple question who runs college
football the oligarchy of the power five
conference commissioners so basically a
group of five guys runs the sport
there's nobody at the NCAA that
seriously matters
you can decide out of those five who the
most important are probably Greg Sankey
of the SEC and Kevin Warren of the Big
Ten and Kevin Warren's brand new what
role does ESPN play in all this well
they certainly have a role no doubt
about it a big role you know I think
that they helped kind of push towards
the creation of the playoff and they
will no doubt have a say in what happens
this season if we have a season when we
have a season what it looks like how
long it lasts and who's involved in the
postseason
I know that we want answers for
something that's supposed to take place
in a couple of months and we can't come
up with answers but it feels like you
know if we set an arbitrary date and
then we don't adhere to that then all of
a sudden you know there's doom and gloom
here at what point do you say if we
don't have something that resembles
football practice by this date then the
seasons in jeopardy you know I think
that you can go as long as August first
before players are on prep on campus and
practicing that would be the latest I
would say for an on time on schedule
season it could be more mid-july people
I've talked to Commissioner zaydis
basically June 1 they want to have a
pretty good idea June 15 they want to
have a better idea
July 1 probably drop dead as far as yes
or no we're going to play starting
August 29th / Labor Day weekend I was
told by a source a couple of days ago
that what you're probably going to look
at and this changes everyday but you'd
have 10 games that you would play 9
would be in the conference and if you
played a game outside the conference you
know oh
State would play Ohio University it'd be
a bus trip you would not but he's but he
said look the pac-12 is the one that's
really in trouble here because of what's
going on in the state and you know
you're all the way up in Washington
you're in Oregon you're in Arizona
that's gonna make it pretty tough what
do you make of those those thoughts yeah
I mean I think that both are viable
thoughts for sure you know I think that
they're looking definitely at models for
a shortened season conference heavy as
you said maybe a non-conference game
they're gonna definitely be trying to
curtail expenses you know the one thing
that the pac-12 obviously is a whole
different different situation right now
but even within conferences dan in the
ACC Clemson may say hey let's go Boston
College may be saying wait a minute in
the big ten Iowa may be saying let's
play Rutgers are saying we can't so this
is gonna be fascinating to me first of
all conference by conference and is this
the beginning of the long discussed
prophesied schism of college football
where a powerful group goes one way and
everybody else goes the other we're not
you know is it where the SEC says we're
playing the big ten says we we're not
sure whether we're playing the pac-12
says no we're not I think that this can
open up some real fractures within the
game that we've already seen at least
talked about for many years yeah I think
those are great points and I I wonder if
it let's say the SEC says we're gonna
we're voting we're playing Vanderbilt
says we can't do that and does the SEC
say all right hey have a nice offseason
here we're gonna play football does the
Big Ten say to Northwestern or Rutgers
sorry guys sorry you can't play like are
we gonna get to that point where you
know it's almost infighting in the in
the own conference
oh I you know I think that the
conference's will do everything they can
to avoid that especially really SEC Big
Ten the SEC is going back to Mike Slive
one of the hallmarks of his tenure was
solidarity we do everything together we
stay in lockstep or an agreement on big
issues even if we're not really that's
the public we're gonna present so
they'll try
to avoid it but yes could it come to
that absolutely you know and I think
that then you're looking at the event
eventually is why is Vanderbilt in our
conference anyway they don't really seem
to fit here or you know why did we bring
Rutgers into the big ten what have they
done exactly so you know I think this
opens up by a big philosophical can of
worms going back to conference
allegiance and alliances you know some
of these that are decades or almost a
century old I mean I think people in the
big 12 have been sitting around if
you're in the state of Texas saying Iowa
state Kansas State really do we need you
so these discussions could be had as we
go along it's bad for tea from Sports
Illustrated senior writer covers not
only college football but basketball as
well and and that's another thing when
you start to look at the schedule if
it's moved back and let's say we're
playing football in this spring do you
have some of these first-round draft
picks who look at this the way Christian
McCaffrey looked at a bowl game and said
you know our Nick BOCES said I'm gonna
shut it down here like I wonder how far
is too far if you're I don't know if
Trevor Lawrence would do this but I I'm
sure you'd have advisors to say let's
look at this and make an educated guess
or decision sure no doubt about it look
Trevor Lawrence my experience around him
is he he's a competitor he's a team guy
loves clubs and he would love to play
but there could very well be some quote
unquote cooler heads that would step in
and say looks on you've got an 80
million dollar future sitting out there
when the NFL Draft happens and then
you're gonna go immediately into a
training camp into a rookie training
camp and then a full-scale training camp
you want to be playing college football
in the spring going right up into that
what if you get hurt what if something
else happens what if you're dead
fatigued in the middle of the 2021
season in the NFL because you played a
late college football season so I think
there's no doubt that those
conversations would be had and I think a
lot of players would look askance at the
spring schedule at least the ones that
are convinced they have a big dollar NFL
future if I said you had a bed a week's
pay if we have football coming up Labor
Day weekend I would bet against at the
moment since my weeks paying very much
it wouldn't be a big
los but I think that you know the hedge
would be if we do have it we're gonna
have it with fewer no fans if you can
give me that better I would take that
otherwise I would say them more likely
if we want if we want to be sure we're
playing football I think it's probably
more likely it's October 1st and I'll
leave you with this I know you love
talking about Rick Pitino no longer at
Louisville but the remnants are still
there NC double-a tap you know knocked
on the door again at at Louisville
here's Rick Pitino at Iona give us sort
of the Cliff Notes version of what's
happening and what could happen in this
situation yeah Louisville got notice of
allegations this week from the NCAA for
not the strippers and hookers scandal
the one after oh this is where they pay
to recruit $100,000 right yes Brian
Bowan some other payments for other
people so they got a one level one
violation allegation which is the most
serious 3 level 2's Pitino I thought was
very fortunate to only get a level two
allegation against him but it's still a
serious deal if that would preclude him
he would not be subject to a show-cause
penalty which could take him out of
things for a longer period of time but
he could be hit with up to a half season
suspension at Iona whenever this thing
grinds through the n-c-double-a process
which could be a year from now so Pitino
not off the hook but probably got away a
little bit lighter than some people
expected Louisville on the other hand
could still get hammered so he could be
coaching theoretically in a postseason
to Louisville is banned from but I
wonder if the NCAA looks at Louisville
they decided to clean house and who are
they a little more lenient on Louisville
because Louisville took the right steps
to get these people out of those
positions yeah that's this is one of
more interesting cases I think in a wild
and for that reason because Louisville
got rid of everybody at a time when
everybody that else that was involved in
the federal corruption probe got rid of
nobody bill self stage Sean Miller
stayed will Wade stay Bruce Pearl stayed
Pitino was going in a day
Tom George the ad was gone in just short
amount of time the president of school
left the Board of Trustees was remade
so they did a lot of things there now
the the cynic among us may point out
well yeah they didn't do anything after
the first camp they waited till the
second one before they got rid of
everybody so it's gonna be an
interesting balancing act I think for
the n-c-double-a to decide do we smash a
school they got rid of everyone or do we
give them credit for good behavior or
reformed behavior Pat great to talk to
you as always thank you thank you Dan
stay healthy that's Pat forty Sports
Illustrated senior writer